welcome back to new rock stars the new
loki trailer ensnares a god of mischief
in a mysterious time
mission with the tva but pursuing whom
is loki's biggest enemy himself i'm eric
voss this is rogue theory with me today
is an amazing panel starting with the
co-host of our [ __ ] winter soldier
after show
mt hey what's going on everybody hey
mt and uh also join us friend of the
show twitch streamer angelica trey
hi hello it's good to be back good to
have you back and also joining us uh
another twitch streamer
uh a friend of me of our own just
glamping i was when you said a friend of
ours a twitch dreamer i was like
oh
i'm not you guys it's so embarrassing to
be like oh i'm the
streamer of this yeah i have 400
followers
uh hey that's big that's nothing to
shake a sticker you start somewhere you
gotta start somewhere i was about to
jump in
i was so embarrassed of myself okay go
on
go on please continue
uh all right let's talk loki a new
trailer for this loki series on disney
plus just dropped revealing a lot more
about loki's partnership with mobius and
mobius owen wilson and the whole time
variants authority
after his escape from um the whole time
heist in avengers end game he's alive
again
uh so uh mobius it kind of explains to
loki
how he disrupted the flow of time uh
splintering it off
in this beautiful timeline graphic oh
just
it made me never need a blue chew ever
that's a again with branches coming off
of it
that's what you're doing timelines okay
and movies and shows
it's such a beautiful thing the
cinematography was really good like the
lighting
i wanted to just do like freeze frames
just get the glow
off of that vintage screen it's just ah
you can't you can't i love the glow of
like the portal doors i like the way
like the little yellow doors
look like yeah but mt let's not get too
distracted timeline
timeline is the sexy part of that
trailer none of the other cool
production design um but we want to talk
about this mystery figure that the tva
is pursuing because we don't have exact
details on how exactly
they need loki to patch the timeline um
we do see these shots of uh
of a hooded female figure most likely
this is actress sophia di martino
so like the shot of loki's sitting next
to this um this woman by a lake
everyone's like is that natasha no it's
not natasha
it's a video martino's character uh and
we don't really know who she is yet but
she is speculated to be
maybe lady loki or enchantress um
but we still don't really know whether
she's gonna be the true villain of the
show or just some kind of misunderstood
figure
it sounds like there's probably gonna be
some old smithville into the show
um who's gonna tell us more about what
loki's real-time mission is and how he's
gonna escape out of the show to join
thor and thor love and thunder
so let's talk about who is the villain
of this show
uh let's let's start with this character
sofia dimartino do we think she's lady
loki do we think she's enchantress
do we think she could be someone else
what do you guys think definitely lady
loki
i think she's lady misunderstood and
there's gonna be
some sort of secret villain coming up
yeah okay so you think beyond her
uh and that she's just someone who's
like a fugitive falsely accused
i didn't kill my wife right and then
there's gonna be a one-armed man behind
it all
yeah and i think there's so many
possibilities too
with the low-key series i mean obviously
so many possibilities
um because there's so many different
timelines going on
so i i definitely think there's going to
be some twists here
even though they could technically just
bring someone out of left field there's
going to be many low-key variants
and you know obviously i think the
biggest twist would to be
you know to make like mobius into some
sort of
villain character but yeah i don't know
there's so many options
i think going off of that because
there's so many realities and so many
variations of loki i think the villain's
going to be loki
uh i think so like it obviously
looks like there's different there's
different timelines there's different
realities
and i think they're going to be fighting
every loki in that reality because who's
better to fight loki
than loki so they're probably like hey
loki we need you to go fight
the original loki which is like the one
in the underworld that's the devil or we
need you to fight old man loki or we
need you to fight
lady loki or ultimates loki so i think
he's gonna be
where i thought in one division where
they were like doing real house of him
and going to different timelines to find
their
their children i think they're going to
be doing in loki where they're going to
go to different timelines and be
fighting other loki's
and that's why we see vote loki that's
why we see president loki for a second
there i thought you were going to say
that
the original loki like the loki we're
following is the villain i was like whoa
like we find out he's the bad guy the
whole time
that would be amazing and i actually
want that now i would love a mobius one
more so because
like because owen wilson is so sweet
gray area
i would love for mobius to secretly be
like a version of loki i think that'd be
really really dope
if he was like secretly local the entire
time but we are getting
um an older version of loki played by
grant if i'm not mistaken
by richard grant yeah is that confirmed
or is that just one of these rumors that
the debate
might be one of those rumors because i i
think we would it would be more
concretely in our minds if it wasn't a
rumor but i'm not sure
anyway we are getting we might be
getting old loki and i really do think
that
yeah like like the girls have been
saying we're gonna get some version of
loki in the show as the main villain um
because i i don't see any other reason
why they would bring loki in
for loki's particular set of skills if
they weren't dealing with
and they did call loki a loki variant
yeah and it says on his jacket
well we know just by the the premise of
the show that he's a loki variant
because the prime
loki or at least the loki from our
perspective is floating out in asgardian
space somewhere
uh so just by his nature he's a variant
already
but i do think that is an interesting
clue it tells us that there are gonna be
multiple loki's so i don't think we're
on the wrong track here
yeah okay but do you think it's gonna
follow with like the comic story lines
and be old loki or do we think it's
gonna be like some sort of twist like
like young loki
kid loki i would love to see a kid loki
like he's gotta die
it would be great like timothy chalamet
or whatever however you spell his last
name
timmy chevy timmy ford i think that's
what you're thinking of right now this
would be laminate
exactly precisely um he would nail it as
a kid loki and i would i'm sure there's
a kid lucky
i'm sure there's gonna be a kid loki in
it we just haven't seen it yet like in
the trailer because that's too much of a
giveaway
like that that'd be wild but that'd be
fun if we see that one and he's gonna
have to like defeat him and he's like
this is a child
i do think we have seen alternate loki's
in uh
in the trailer i think president loki in
the trailer he is talking to someone
else i don't think he's breaking the
fourth wall he's talking to our loki
that we're following
uh i think the uh the other loki that we
see in the battle in new york i don't
think that's our loki i think that's
past
loki from that past timeline and we're
gonna see multiple loki's which is fun
because loki already has the power to
like project uh uh fake versions of
himself are we just gonna see like
two different loki's that are using that
same power fi
they're different hollow projections
fighting each other uh just to see which
one has
the better mastery of their own sorcery
true
but how do we even know if they're like
the same loki
what if every single shot in that
trailer is a different loki
oh i think so i think so cooper loki i
think that's going to be a different
loki
it's tough because you know every once
in a while i have people say no it's
confirmed that she's going to be
enchantress sylvie lushton and i'm like
where was
that confirmed and then someone will
tweet me just a screen grab of some
4chan
leak that says that richard e grant is
confirmed to play old loki that
enchantress is confirmed to be sophia d
martinez character it's like well some
of this might be true
but some of this might just be it's like
the same people said oh well uh
zemo's gonna be the villain and isaiah
bradley's gonna be a [ __ ] winner
soldier it's like if you could just
look at the basic tea leaves you can now
say that you claim this to be a leak and
then use this to
make future predictions and it's not
true it's just [ __ ]
so i'm not using this as evidence of
anything right now it could end up being
the case but
so i'm gonna trust footage that i see in
the trailer more than
someone something someone says on reddit
somewhere uh
and they have a mixed bag track record
but eric yeah 4chan told me that isaiah
bradley was going to be the new marvel
big bad after thanos
yeah 4th channel trump was going to be
president again on march the 4th
but uh you know oh sorry that was eight
minutes
jim watkins you know yeah yeah
oh boy oh boy but uh can we talk about
kang is it too soon like some people are
getting on us they're saying that the
mandarin could show up in falcon winter
soldiers were like no
he's the villain of shang chi it's like
have you seen the mcu for the past 10
years
they always introduced a character
earlier uh just to get us a sense of who
they are and then later they come back
you know thanos was the villain in uh
infinity war but we saw him at the end
of adventures in guardians of the galaxy
so there's no reason to believe that
these people can't be teased early in
these tv shows to acquaint audiences
with them
before they become the big villain of a
later series is it possible we see kang
in this
oh yes absolutely there's like there is
no way that we don't at least get kang
teased in this because ant-man 3 is
coming out very very soon
and with the time variance authority
being introduced there is
absolutely no i'm very very confident
that we will at least get a
cane tease and with um the kang actor
already being cast
yeah anything can happen but he can
literally pop up any time yeah and and
they you know with the the time variance
authority and with all of these you know
possible different like
timelines and variants um you know kang
in
in some of the comics like he plays
around with time travel
and he has kind of like other variants
as well like he doesn't know which form
he's going to come back in so this would
be
really amazing for drawing parallels
with loki and and his different variants
and jessica i think you are right
definitely in that like
alternate loki's are going to be uh
antagonist
star loki i'm just kind of wondering you
know it's interesting we talk about kang
because that's kind of how kang is
there's so many different kangs they're
part of the kang dynasty
and then at the end of it all you have
kang prime who's that
in limbo at the end of all time who's
just kind of uh feeding off all these
paradoxes that other versions of kang
have made at different points in history
and different timelines is
or we can see a version that with loki
are they saying like there's going to be
loki prime maybe that could be richard e
grant's character
and that that would be could be right
there with your theory i feel like the
most supreme loki is loki from ultimate
so i feel like
making that look which is like too much
for me to be sane
but it's like that loki has like every
type of power
plus is just like a i don't know i think
he's a stronger loki
so if that loki is like ultimately the
loki we see versus the loki in hell that
might be the prime loki
i feel like that's who he's gonna have
to fight and that's gonna be hard and i
think that's when we're gonna see like
that loki magic that we saw in the
trailer
and it's like oh this isn't the loki we
know because our loki can't do this with
his hands
but i think i think so i just don't know
whether it's going to be hell loki or
ultimates loki
wait going back to what when we were
talking about kang and variance and all
that stuff
with um as we know we're sort of getting
young avengers
teases throughout these uh disney plus
shows
and we've gotten uh eli bradley in uh
falcon winter soldier
but iron lad or i believe it's iron lad
um in
in the young avengers uh is actually
kang a younger version of yeah
so we could maybe see this younger
version of kang
at some point either in loki or i don't
know maybe falcon winter soldier maybe
he's like hey i'm here now hello eli
no no it's well it's often because a lot
of people want uh the kid from iron man
3 to be the mcu version of iron lad
but they're only taking the name iron
lad whereas really iron lad in the
comics is more of like a fusion of stark
tech from vision
it's kind of a rebooted vision and he
already has like a suit
from the future uh that is like kind of
his identity now and then when he goes
back to the past he kind of gets uh some
vision os software
to restart the avenger initiative and
then he assembles it with like stature
and eli bradley and all them and just
going off of what mt said right with all
the different variants
loki could be traveling through these
different
time periods and then also fighting
different types of
of kings so like there is what is it the
pharaoh kang like this
and then the iron lad one this could get
real zany
and he could like bring the loki's thing
yeah yeah and he could bring in
the other loki's like to possibly help
him you know
in in some way obviously there are all
you know wild cards in a sense but
if they have like a common interest this
show can get really really wild
it could be amazing i would love to see
different versions of kang like a donkey
kang
a dd uh just also
king kang versus uh godzilla all that
[ __ ]
i like donkey king yeah yeah i i think
ultimately what we're looking at
is uh some kind of rogue loki who is
uh wreaking too much havoc after loki
opened the pandora's box of splitting
away from the timeline
and then each of those timelines could
just refer to a different loki now we
only have six episodes though
so they're they're not gonna go it's not
gonna be like a full 22 episode season
of quantum leap
where at some point he's going to jump
into harriet tubman's body and say oh
boy
i'm harriet tubman we're not going to
get that yeah no no
long arcs or anything it's going to be
to the point
my favorite loki line oh boy i'm harriet
tub
oh goodness gracious quote
quote the low-key yeah i'm here for that
okay that'll be the next teaser honestly
so let us know in the comments below
which uh villain
option that we brought up that you think
could be the kind of ultimate big bad of
this series is it gonna be an alternate
version of loki is someone we've seen in
the trailers before
is it gonna be the tva i kind of hope
not i want the tva to
i don't want them to get uh hydrated or
shielded you know how she
would be pretty much i kind of want them
just to be this goofy
impenetrable bureaucratic agency i love
the tvs
so i'm always annoying
yeah so uh i think the the
golden goose of this
uh will go to uh jessica for suggesting
it's gonna be just a prime version of
loki himself yeah
you get the point give me that golden
goose
give me that gobble gobble [ __ ]
the goose gobble gobble does not go the
goo i said it out loud then i was like
wait does it go the goose gobble doesn't
go the goose
if there's anything i remember from
elementary school it's gobble does not
go the goose
we're gonna move on to the fact of the
winter soldier and what dance master
zemo
is really planning but first a few words
from the folks who helped us make rogue
theory starting with their friends at
bespoke post
if you have some spring adventures on
the brain take bespoke post with you
they're ready to upgrade your life with
a new lineup of essential box of awesome
collections for guys
i got a great new rain jacket in a box
of awesome recently
and in the past i've gotten cool travel
bags bar gear
and camping supplies they got it all
bespoke post only sends guys the best
stuff every month no matter what you're
into box of awesome as you cover it from
style and grooming goods
to cooking goods boss of awesome has
collections for every part of your life
they've even got a new retreat box with
a hammock
and a matching picnic blanket and a
turbo box
with automotive themed coffee products
yeah
to get started take the quiz at box of
awesome.com your answers will help them
pick the right box of awesome for you
they release new boxes every month
across a ton of different categories
it's free to sign up and you can skip a
month or cancel anytime
each box only costs 45 bucks but has
over 70 dollars worth of gear inside
get twenty percent off your first
monthly box when you sign up at box of
awesome dot com
and enter the code rogue at checkout
that's box of awesome dot com
code rogue for twenty percent off your
first box we also wanna thank our
friends at helix
it's gotta be hard for zemo to get a
good night's sleep on those prison
mattresses
you know they're not customizing them
for each prisoner well i don't know
maybe that german prison
will they tend to be seem to be totally
okay with people just like walking out
minimum security well uh don't sleep on
a mattress designed for someone else
folks helix sleep has a quiz that
matches
your body type and your sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you
they have soft medium and firm
mattresses mattresses great for cooling
down if you sleep hot
even a helix plus mattress for plus size
sleepers i took the quiz and got matched
with the dusk luxe helix mattress
because i wanted a medium firm mattress
with lumbar support that sleeps cool and
i'm getting
great sleep on my helix mattress the
mattress comes right to your door
shipped for free and you never need to
go to a mattress store again
they were awarded the number one best
overall mattress pick of 2020 by gq and
wired magazine
go to helixsleep.com rogue theory take
their two minutes sleep quiz and they'll
match you to the customized mattress
that will give you the best sleep of
your life they have a 10 year warranty
and you get to try it out 100 nights
risk-free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our audience at helix sleep.com
rogue theory that's helix sleep.com
rogue theory for up to
200 off and two free pillows oh uh also
if you've been following our weekly
fitness origin series you know that
philip is putting tommy and me through
workouts as part of his fun
mcu theme fitness challenge the whole
experience has reminded me of the
importance of living a healthy life
which we want you guys to join in on
i want to be around a long time to make
these videos and i want you to be around
to watch them so follow along and do the
same workouts tommy and i are doing over
at
epic hero fitness channel so subscribe
to the epic hero fitness channel
to follow our journey and you can do the
workouts and catch
some upcoming bloopers and out i watched
it it's very fun
i love watching you work out [ __ ]
that's sweet it's very fun it's very
nice i was watching it while i was
running on a treadmill too
no joke i straight up i watched it all
while on a treadmill i felt like i was
working out with you guys
all right we're moving on to the fact
that zemo is back in the mcu on the
falcon the winter soldier
broken free way too easily and using his
vast financial resources to jet set
with bucky and samuel magipore bust a
few moves
and then the latvia all in pursuit of
this super soldier serum and the flag
smashers now
remember zebo's goal in civil war was to
rid the world of the avengers after
their superheroics wrecked sokovia and
got his family killed
and his hatred of super soldiers led him
to kill all the other winter soldiers
and he said in episode three of the
falcon wing soldier that he hunted down
a lot of hydra scientists who are trying
to replicate the super soldier serum and
we see him
take the next step of that and plugging
dr wilfred nagel aka someone who does
very good jesse eisenberg from batman v
superman
oh that's exactly what i was thinking
every time i saw him i'm like this is a
good jessie i think of eisenberg
well now uh zemo and bucky and sam's
goals seem to all be
on the same track but zemo's hiding
something what is he not telling them
what is he not telling us he seems to
have some kind of ace up his sleeve
uh asap mislead ace in the whole trick
up your sleeve trick-or-treat i think
we're all magicians towed in the hole
he's definitely gonna do something
sneaky
he killed that doctor a little too
quickly yeah
oh yeah yeah as if that doctor knew
something more that um
he didn't want them to keep confessing
they exchanged a look when they walked
in
and then yeah that the two view they had
two cuts to him being like not
don't look at my mouth but like yeah
just like that
like don't like my mouth but look at my
eyes he obviously
he made that face and so that's why i do
think he's working
which i also would love i think this is
why i'm on this theory that he's working
with the flag smashers
because that reveal will be so insane to
be like it won't be so
insane but it would be surprising to be
like in what world do you align your
political beliefs with theirs and it's
like
uh because you guys weren't here oh so
what do you think
um what do you think is their ultimate
plan then if he's working if he's in
league
i think he's what are they well only
because he killed nagel
i thought because as soon as he killed
nago i was like okay they're giving out
too much information
and he doesn't want them to find it
before he finds it i am
zima so i think he killed him to be like
i'm gonna relay this information to the
other people rather than
relay it to these two people that i
really deeply hate so i think
he's gonna meet up with him eventually i
don't know i don't know he's a rich guy
so there could be millions of ways he's
getting his information to the flag
smashers
but i think overall he ultimately is
working with the flags masters for them
he's like
i'm cheering you guys on even if they
don't know who he is
like directly yet um yeah so i hope that
makes sense that's what i well it's hard
to know exactly what the flag smashers
goal is because
honestly they were part of some deleted
subplot with vaccines and there was some
pandemic subplot there
and they based on the editing so far
they are butchering up their
their scenes where it's just very
confusing what their goal is
they had to be tested on by nagel right
that's what i assumed
oh i think they stole it they were in
madrid
saying that after they were kicked out
of their homes after the blip that the
only place they could go to make a
living was madrapore
they found nagel they stole the fizzy
lifting drinks
good day sir you lose
themselves up with that stuff they
talked about how their bones were on
fire whatever
and now they want to give it to the kids
but it just seems like
that was even part of a reshoot that
scene was just kind of confusing
yeah that sounds backwards what is your
fault then yeah
yeah backwards yeah we don't know what's
going on
fully with the flag smashers right now
but i definitely think
the power broker is going to come up and
i don't know how zemo
would relate to that but i think that's
going to be like one of our
our final final villains and then zemo's
going to pull like a switcheroo
i feel like he probably before the whole
lab you know
um you know went went to
you know burst into flames basically um
i feel like
zemo probably grabbed some of those like
the samples
in there yeah i think he's gonna do so
yeah i think he's gonna do something
sneaky like he's been playing the sneaky
route this whole time we've gotten some
peaks of that mask
yeah was he the last one to get in the
car was he the last one to get in the
car when they all did he was or was he
the
but no he was the same he ran off he
drove the car up i'm on a jelly because
i love angelica's theory i
i keep going yeah yeah well he walked in
there with a game plan
and that's why he enacted it so quickly
so i i know that
he's got something up his sleeve yeah
and he's just kind of playing like the
fun dancing guy
you know the the fun rich daddy friend
yeah daddy baron yeah well let's look at
it let's frame it this way
uh there's you know with any villain
subplot it usually can be
either boiled down to are they trying to
build something or are they trying to
destroy something
yes right does is he ambitious or is he
out for revenge
and a civil war he was out for revenge
he was trying to destroy the avengers he
wasn't trying to build something new uh
uh you know so in his case he's a
machiavellian
and he talks about you know as to be a
machiavellian it means you're constantly
kind of
jumping around no one really can pin you
down and so if he's trying to just get
revenge it's kind of an extension of
civil war right he's he's
currently playing on sam and bucky's
team but really he's still just trying
to eradicate the rest of the avengers
but if he's trying to build something we
could be looking at he's trying to build
his own avengers trying to build the
thunderbolts or something like that
see i think that zemo is definitely
i think that he his mission from civil
war is still intact and i think that
zemo
wants to use carly to some degree
because he says in the last episode
i for one am am looking forward to
meeting carly morgenthau
and i think all of this comes together
because carly's main goal
is to get rid of symbols and that's sort
of what zemo wants to do i think that
the the symbol of captain america itself
is 100
against what zemo's all about so i think
that zemo
by working with the flag smashers um is
going to try to
just like rip off just iconography and
like and just
get rid of just icons like like you said
red skull was a problem because people
worshipped him like an
icon so i think that he wants to meet up
with carly probably inspire her because
she's just a young
person who doesn't really have all that
much leadership and he's like this
criminal mastermind so i think zemo's
gonna be like hello child let me
let me help you become evil like me
could there be a world
where zemo is related to carly i mean
potentially
i mean it's a world where zemo's related
to red skull it's crazy
i'm not jumping on that train yet he has
a ton of wealth johann schmidt was super
wealthy and like they they made a whole
point in this episode talking about he
had old family money
so it's just like what was you know you
know the the wayne family were bird
trappers
right so what was the the zemo family
all about were they just royalty i
didn't even know that sokovia was
uh a monarchy system i thought it was
just like a male democracy
baron zemo could just be loki in
disguise this entire time
i'm just saying wouldn't that be
crazy okay let's go we have to compare
dance moves now
all right how does loki dance
we need to go back and watch every clip
with loki dancing and make sure it
aligns
perfectly with baron zmo the the rest of
this entire video is actually just going
to be 10 minutes
so on a loop of the dancing and i will
first over both
the entire time i will go nuts for it
but no going back to zmel real quick um
i think that another
uh potential secret motivation behind
zemo is that now he knows about isaiah
bradley which
may not be the best of things because as
we've seen isaiah's blood is was being
used to create
more super soldiers and so if isaiah is
just walking around
old and alive and i'm zemo i'm like all
right i'm going to kill this old guy
with this uh with super powered blood
isaiah bradley just
can't be alive if he doesn't want super
soldiers and superheroes to exist
does baron know about isaiah so that
like
that interaction has happened already
that they've talked about him here's the
thing
so on the plane in the last episode when
sam is talking to bucky about
um isaiah bradley we see zemo take a
peek over at sam like like he's
listening if you look back
you can see it i'm just like my ears are
burning
[Laughter]
okay that's a great find mt and i think
it does tell us something
i think the public knowledge of isaiah
bradley is something that actually
hurts captain america's legacy uh in the
public view and
i don't think the government wants
people to know that isaiah bradley
existed
or existed true and i think zemo's
ultimate goal might just be to
completely disgrace the captain america
legacy
so right now that's why he's working
with sam and with bucky is because
they're
being also kind of like anti-cat because
they're anti-john walker
but i think zemo's ultimate goal might
be to like drive john walker
further and further insane maybe by
giving him one of these half-baked
serums
uh and turn this guy into a murderous
madman get it on camera and said this
is who your government wants captain
america to be and that's of that
shield is just a pariah now and i think
that zemo is like mission accomplished
but doesn't ultimately leave that does
america
more than he hates the avengers i don't
know i think he hates the idea of
superheroes
i mean he hates an america that wants to
support the idea of a superhero
like captain america but ultimately you
know he hated tony stark
uh but ultimately iron man was the one
who was able to walk away or but
ultimately captain america was the one
who's able to walk away from that
in-game battle
and captain america is one whose legacy
is continued
to be propped up and i think zemo wants
to
just drag that through the mud that
includes telling everyone the truth
about isaiah bradley it's true that
everyone needs to know
but the more people know about isaiah
bradley the more people kind of hate the
history of steve rogers
i think something's gonna go down with
this new cap
um but also is there a possibility where
zemo could
take the super soldier serum himself i
know like as a means to an end
is there a possibility of this probably
that would be very fun
it is quite possible it would be very
you know abnormal
because zemo's so against it but like
you said as a means to an end
yeah baby that makes him such a wild
card right just going back to the
machiavellian thing
yeah you know he says we had to we had
to do it
because that's that's how we you know
maybe even out the playing field
you know i had to do it on him watch him
take the needle and inject it into
someone else
like i don't know i hope it's weird
because it is like he is so against that
potion whatever you want the potion he's
so against it
serum potion wizards medicine
so
[Laughter]
very good don't quote me on that i
wouldn't
that's the teaser for this episode which
is medicine whatever
what is this modern medicine is magic
what's in the vaccine what's in there no
one knows
super soldier i hope it's okay i got
mine today
are you stronger could you take
a bottle and throw it through the wall
yeah
uh i have asthma but they're all
completely okay we're changing the
subject i'm so sorry
i have asthma and let me tell you the
covet podcast this is the company
all right now we're we're sorry guys
we're switching it up we're talking
about asthma today i can't get this
an asthma awareness video how long has
zemo had asthma let's get into this
asthma everybody put your asthma
inhalers to the screen and
take a hit and pass it so um
i think that would be interesting if he
did like he is so against the serum but
if he did
take it and he put it in like sam that'd
be pretty messed up
because it makes like sam and freaking
bucky both
um like super soldiers and so i don't
know i feel like sam
bucky would be like that's the last part
like no one else should get this serum
and then they'll put it into who's gonna
be his best friend eventually
eventually uh would be i think uh i
think ultimately
one of those files is gonna end up in
the hands of eli bradley
and it's gonna be that kind of choice
like do i juice myself up because eli
bradley that was his whole thing in the
young avengers is he was using the
mutant growth hormone yeah
he's just gonna have a violin as jordan
just be like i'll save it for now and
that's gonna be a whole
conflict with him how does he get it
do you think they get it out to
everybody i i think someone snatched a
couple of those vials
on the way out of that lab and then
that's gonna be now the kind of the the
football the macguffin of this is you're
gonna have the shield and then you're
gonna have a leftover vial of that but i
i do think that by the end of this
series we might actually see sam
juiced up do you think um interesting oh
you think
either sam and or torres i think that
there will be some sort of
um augmentation there with one of those
someone has to die someone has to die
just something's happening with sharon
and i'm just trying to figure it out
sharon shane
she's different from what i remember
last summer sharon
sharon sharon ever since you've gone
sharon you hated us um so i feel like
sharing should be like an
art camp and she thinks she's better
than us she thinks oh my god
she i think it's going to be torres that
dies taurus has to die
like no he doesn't he doesn't have to
but it would be
it would be sad it would be really sad
if he does die
and so i think that's why he's a nice
dude i was mean on him the first
uh episode don't trust this guy because
i thought he was a little too eager to
you know mess around with red wing tech
and i'm like he's part of that
conspiracy
you know two episodes later it's like
until he got his ass
we've heard from him is when he's a nice
guy he's just helping out sam from afar
so i don't know i think sam would get it
more so than torres
but do you think mt that torrez would
get it and that's where we get
um him as like falcon oh yeah like we're
definitely gonna get some type of
i don't know augmented torres to some
degree because
torres does have um history with with
being augmented in some way by carl
malus
so i i i definitely think we're going to
get the origins of
torres falcon within the show okay i'm
setting himself up for either
a champions which i highly doubt but
like probably younger
than yeah that's just me
mt i'm gonna give you the point here for
that uh nemo
over the shoulder look when he's like
making them on the plane
but not the look that i made as zemo
covering my mouth
yeah you'll get uh you guys that's a
good one you get a half point
yes there you go that's all you have to
do you guys cry about it and you will
win
you will get the point angelica okay i
think you deserve a point for something
uh yeah for well i don't know if this is
going to make the card with that
inhaler dance okay oh i guess yeah
that was it whatever i i i'm uh a
pushover i'm gonna be the pushover dad
oh daddy all right we're now moving on
into rogue questions uh
really we just have one question because
the king of this week was godzilla
versus kong
number one movie at the box office so
uh if you need another movie to bring in
that we can build that we can make them
fight
let them fight what other movie would be
the most
appropriate movie to fight and defeat
godzilla versus kong
what if it was like lilo versus stitch
and they have to fight each other
that's a really short terrible graphic
movement
so imagine okay so imagine like the
terminator the newest one like kind of
intro
and then it's just like lilo being like
i have to defeat him and it's like older
lilo
and she's just like an older lady and
she's like i gotta go and fight them
and it's stitched just like romantic and
rabbit just like rare and so it's like
older lilo versus like a rabbit stitch
and she has like a gun for an arm or
something like
imagine that that would be very funny oh
i love that
is this directed by tarantino yeah i
know
rodriguez okay
unrealistic goals you know what i'm the
same sort of vein i'm gonna go
even crazier because i think a a
crossover movie
between aliens the alien franchise and
the magic school bus
miss frizzle fight xenomorphs
in a in in outer space with the kids
and they're trying to escape and it'd be
amazing i'm only saying this because i
had this idea betty boone's ago
and i would just really want it to
happen out now
aliens edition for me
i like it and not not magic school bus
where they go inside of a body and have
to fight coronavirus
oh oh well wait a minute wait a minute
that one sounds good
okay so at first my like my brain just
thought of a big franchise
and i was like what if they brought back
like astro boy or something i just want
to see
some astro boy stuff come back but i i
don't know who to pit astro boy against
so
then my brain jumped to like zombies
versus vampires
so there you go there's hordes of
zombies and they're fighting vampires
i love it so yeah yeah do you like that
yeah who's gonna get the most blood in
the end honestly i think zombies take
that one well yeah because they're
zombies yeah
yeah they have fewer limitations
vampires what happens when a zombie
bites a vampire and a vampire bites a
zombie
well uh i gotta give it to jessica for
lilo versus stitch
get that amber stand out of there get a
verse
lvs i'm all about it yes uh that makes
jessica
our winner of this week
all three of you had some wonderful
tastes on these subjects i hope
everything that you pitched comes true
at some point
either in this universe or another uh i
want to thank our guests
uh mt angelica trey and jessica clements
follow all three of them on social media
follow them on twitch
uh whether they're established
experienced twitch streamers like
angelica is
or just getting started sparkle in a
dream and her what is this comparison
i know i'm a little hurt hey
jessica if you if you want to play
phasmaphobia together or something
we could play some games together okay
yeah i've been dying to play
phasmaphobia yeah baby streamers
are the coolest people ever if you
consider yourself
babies yeah yeah so whatever let's do it
we will game you guys look out for us
playing basketball
make your dream come true
and jessica's got a whole google doc
with their top muppet babies
people every time you bring up that damn
muppet dog people come at me i'm sorry
in a good way it's fine it's always like
releasing stop coming at jessica
there's she's released as much of it as
she can release
just go find that i gotta change it up
now that everyone's corrected me
yeah no what you have is correct what
you have is fine it's
uh miss piggy's at the top that's all
that matters look stick stick
yeah stick to it honestly at this point
thank you
this is a virtue stupidness is a virtue
thank you so much
we'll call it that that's right um
support our channel by checking out one
of our many great merch options at
newarkstarsmerch.com i'm wearing a
falcon winter soldier inspired anarchy
assembled shirt
oh he's looking good great oh thanks
it's the only shirt i'm allowed to wear
now
but it's not true not true not true i
just love it so much
uh so get your hands on this one you can
follow me at eavos on instagram and
twitter follow new rockstar subscribe to
new rockstars here on youtube and uh
keep an eye out because coming tomorrow
morning we're going to be with our after
show for episode four of falcon winter
soldier yeah
uh so very excited and uh we'll see you
all next time bye
[Music]
you